في سن ال 19 ، كيلي توماس ، امرأة شابة
نشأت في مزرعة للماشية
وأصيبت فارسًا متعطشًا بجروح في
حادث شاحنة انقلاب ، كسرت رقبتي في C 71
وأصيبت في العمود الفقري وكانت
مشلولة من صدرها إلى أسفل ،
أخبرها أطباؤها أنها لن تفعل ذلك أبدًا  المشي
مرة أخرى ولكن في فبراير بعد ثلاث سنوات
من حادثها ،
تحدى توماس جميعهم لاتخاذ هذه
الخطوات الأولى ، كيف شعرت أن
هذا الجهاز الصغير وضعها على قدميها
جراحيًا ، حيث يرسل
نبضات كهربائية إلى عمودها الفقري يحاكي
الإشارات التي استخدمها دماغها  أرسل
قبل وقوع
الحادث وبعد سبعة أشهر أحرزت توماس
مزيدًا من التقدم ، يمكنها
المشي في منزلها والدخول إلى حمامها ورؤية
انعكاس صورتها واقفة في المرآة
يمكنها المشي على طول شرفتها الأمامية أو
عبر العشب في فناء منزلها الذي
يصعب اجتيازه.  يمكنك الذهاب إلى المكتبة
أو المشي لتناول العشاء مع الأصدقاء ، فهذا
يجعلني أشعر بأنني طبيعي مرة أخرى ، لقد أوضحت لي
كيف تم إيقاف جهاز التحفيز الخاص بك الآن ،
هل يمكنك التحرك؟  لا يمكنني
الآن السماح لك بتشغيل ساقينا على هذا
الإعداد الذي اخترته ، يمكنني تحريك
ساقي وهذا مذهل ، هاه
تم الإبلاغ عن إنجازها الهائل هذا الأسبوع في
مجلة نيو إنجلاند الطبية
في دراسة أجراها باحثون في
جامعة
تم زرع لويزفيل للمرضى المصابين بالشلل بالجهاز
اثنان منهم توماس وتمكن هذا الرجل
من المشي مرة أخرى بعد
تدريب بدني مكثف. وتؤكد دراسة أخرى
هذا الأسبوع من مايو كلينيك
هذه النتائج ،
أفاد الباحثون أن أحد مرضاهم المشلولين
سار أيضًا.  بعد الحصول على جهاز
تحفيز
ولكن مع المساعدة التي أصبت بالشلل ،
لم تتمكن من تحريك ساقيك والآن
يمكنك المشي ما هي الكلمة التي ستستخدمها
لوصف كيف تشعر
أنها خارج هذا العالم ، فكل
خطوة مبهجة ومرهقة لقدمي
هذا أمر صعب  العمل ، فأنت لا تشغل
المحفز فقط وتذهب
بشكل صحيح تمامًا ، فهذا ليس حلاً سريعًا
للإصابة بالشلل في كل
خطوة  لأنها تأمل
أن يمر الآخرون يومًا ما بتحول مشابه
لن يتمكن أي شيء
من إيقافي في الحياة لأنني أخذت
شيئًا كان يُعتقد أنه
مستحيل عندما حولته إلى
إليزابيث كوهين المحتملة. CNN LA Kanto
Florida